Hey guys, you guys have heard of ASMR, right? So Ed, do we know what ASMR stands for? What's the deal with it? What's the deal with what you guys are talking about? ASMR is when you talk really slow. Does it feel like I'm everywhere in your head? Can we guess what the acronym is for something? Yeah, sure, go ahead.
大家好，你们都听说过ASMR吧？所以，埃尔德，我们知道ASMR代表什么吗？这到底是怎么回事？你们在讨论的到底是怎么回事？ASMR就是当你说话非常慢的时候。感觉我无处不在，就在你的脑海里吗？我们能猜出这个缩写代表什么吗？可以，当然，请说。
Acute sound. I need to ask you again, does it feel like I'm just everywhere? Because I am, I'm in your head. I am you. Yeah. I am all of you. Acute sound. Jason, close your eyes.
敏锐的声音。我需要再问你一次，感觉我真的无处不在吗？因为我确实在，我在你的脑海里。我就是你。是的。我就是你们所有人。敏锐的声音。杰森，闭上眼睛。
Close your eyes. Look, it's me. In here. I'm in here with you. I'm gonna go, I'm gonna go upstairs. I'm gonna turn on the camera. Oh my God. How did you get in here?
闭上眼睛。看，是我。在这里。我和你在这里。我要走了，我要上楼了。我要打开摄像头。哦，天哪。你是怎么进来的？
Okay. I think we got it. We got it. Rob wants to help. Rob wants to help. Rob wants to help. Rob wants to help. Rob wants to help.
好吧。我想我们明白了。我们明白了。罗布想帮忙。罗布想帮忙。罗布想帮忙。罗布想帮忙。罗布想帮忙。
Rob wants to help. Rob wants to help. Rob wants to help. Rob wants to help. So guys, I'm sorry I'm late. I start with a reason why you're not wearing a hat. Why we got to look at what we're... Is skevo on holiday?
罗布想帮忙。罗布想帮忙。罗布想帮忙。罗布想帮忙。所以，伙计们，抱歉我迟到了。我先解释一下你为什么不戴帽子。为什么我们要看我们……Skevo去度假了吗？
What's going on with skevo? No, on skevo. Did we talk last time about that I met skevo? No. No, but I know that you did. Yeah, yeah, yeah. So I was in there getting this done to my head. Oh, it looks good, by the way, Jay.
Skevo怎么了？不，关于Skevo。我们上次聊过我遇到Skevo的事吗？没有。没有，但我知道你遇到了。对，对，对。所以我当时在里面弄我的头。哦，顺便说一句，看起来不错，杰。
I paid for it, believe it. It looks really good. Stop it. It does the lightness better. And then there was skevo. And skevo, like, is not nearly as... God, I gotta say this kindly. The name will point you in a certain direction of anticipation.
我花钱买的，信不信由你。看起来真不错。别这样。这样显得更轻盈一点。然后是Skevo。Skevo，怎么说呢，远没有……天哪，我得客气点说。这个名字会让你对某种期待产生方向感。
And here's this, like, Greek god. And he's beautifully short of that. Yeah. Yeah, he's a pretty cool dude. Yeah. Okay, so Sean, so you're sorry you're late today because... I was one minute late. I'm not making this up.
而这里有这样一个，呃，希腊神。他完全当之无愧。对。对，他是个挺酷的家伙。对。好吧，肖恩，那你今天迟到了是因为……我迟到了一分钟。我可没瞎编。
I literally just went to the mail and something was dropped over the fence and it's for Scotty and it's from this company. Bear bottom. B-E-A-R-B-O double... It literally describes him in two words. A bear bottom... He's a bear and he's a bottom. Listen, this is great to know.
我刚刚去取信，有个东西被扔在栅栏那边，是给斯科蒂的，来自这家公司。Bear bottom。B-E-A-R-B-O双……这简直用两个词形容了他。一个“熊底”（Bear bottom）……他是一只熊，而且是个受。听着，知道这个太棒了。
I swear to God, I just picked it up in the mail. Does it say noisy on the other side? Does it say power? It's sloppy. So what does bear bottom make for clothing? I don't know. Should I open it? Oh, they're nice.
我发誓，我刚从邮箱里拿出来的。另一面写着“吵闹”吗？写着“力量”吗？太马虎了。那Bear bottom生产什么服装？我不知道。我应该打开它吗？哦，它们挺好看的。
Oh, they're like shorts. Oh, they're just shorts. They're shorts. I would like to say the one thing I did think about to... I mean, we rarely do think of anything to say on this show, non-shocker. It's important. It's just how much this is not working for me, Will. You spending your summer out of town.
哦，它们就像短裤。哦，它们就是短裤。它们是短裤。我想说的一件事是，我曾考虑过要……我是说，我们在这个节目里很少会想出什么要说的话，毫不意外。这很重要。只是这对我太不管用了，威尔。你把夏天花在外地。
I don't know. I don't get it. I mean, I get you've got a lot of money and people with a lot of money need to figure out ways to spend it and you found one there. But this isn't working for us. Well, like Jay and I are going to the Dodgers game tonight. Yeah, and like you should be there. I was invited to go with you guys.
我不知道。我不明白。我是说，我明白你有很多钱，钱多的人需要想办法把钱花掉，而你在那儿找到了一个。但这对我们不管用。好吧，就像我和杰今晚要去看道奇队的比赛。对，而且你本该去的。我被邀请和你们一起去了。
Obviously, you know that and I would love to go with you and... But who is this good for? I bet you it weirds the kids out. The dogs probably all freaked out. What's this house? Well, the kids were missing you. The kids love it. The kids love being out here and, you know, obviously I used to live in New York.
显然，你知道的，我很乐意和你们一起去，而且……但这到底对谁有好处？我敢打赌这把孩子们吓得够呛。狗可能也全都抓狂了。这房子是怎么回事？好吧，孩子们一直在想你。孩子们很喜欢。孩子们喜欢呆在这里，而且，显而易见，我以前住在纽约。
And so I sold my apartment and I bought a house out at the beach, which is why I'm here and I like it out here. I think I do not sing Long Island anymore. I mean, let's stop hiding. You live in the Hamptons, you know? How many very Range Rovers are in the driveway? Zero. You got those in LA?
所以我卖了我的公寓，在海滩买了一栋房子，这就是为什么我在这里，而且我喜欢这里。我想我不再唱长岛之歌了。我是说，别再掩饰了。你住在汉普顿，你知道的？车道上有多少辆亮眼的揽胜？零。你在洛杉矶有那些吗？
All GMCs. They're all GMCs. Why? Because they're professional. Well, we are professional grades. Sure. I got a new AT4X on its way. It's a beautiful pickup truck from GMC. I saw pictures of that. It's good looking.
全是GMC。它们全都是GMC。为什么？因为它们很专业。好吧，我们是专业级别的。当然。我有一辆新的AT4X在路上了。那是GMC的一款漂亮皮卡。我看到它的照片了。长得挺好看。
It's real handsome. I'm coming out there in two weeks. It's got a multi-pro tailgate. No, you're coming out in two weeks, Sean. What are you guys coming for? One night. What night is it? I don't remember.
它真的很帅。我两周后就要去那儿了。它有一个多功能尾门。不，你两周后要来，肖恩。你们是来干什么的？一晚。那是哪一晚？我不记得了。
Just one night. I don't understand. Because then you're flying to come see me. Where are you going to spend seven nights with me? Well, maybe like four. Really? We're going to get a tour of NASA in Florida first. Before I see you.
就一晚。我不明白。因为接着你要飞去看我。你要在哪儿和我共度七个晚上？好吧，大概四天吧。真的吗？我们首先要在佛罗里达参观NASA。在我见你之前。
And then you're going to go to the Bahamas and do a tour of NASA. Wonderful, Will. Are we rolling, guys? Did you get any of that? I love getting instant feedback. Anyway, let's get to it. Let's get to it. Because I think you're going to be happy.
然后你要去巴哈马群岛参观NASA。太棒了，威尔。我们在录制吗，伙计们？你们录到什么了吗？我喜欢获得即时反馈。不管怎样，我们开始吧。我们开始吧。因为我觉得你们会高兴的。
Okay. Today, we have a man who is half of a famous comedy duo. He's been educated by the smart folks at Sarah Lawrence. He's performed at Second City in Chicago, Sean. He's starred in two big TV shows,
好了。今天，我们请到了一位男士，他是一个著名喜剧二人组的一半。他接受过莎拉劳伦斯学院聪明之士的教育。他在芝加哥的第二城剧团表演过，肖恩。他主演了两部大型电视剧，
probably more, just not good at research. Produced a few of them, probably more, not good at research. He's voiced characters in multiple animated hit films. But you know him and love him for his recent work behind the camera as a writer, producer, and bad-ass director of three incredible films,
可能更多，只是不擅长做调查。制作了其中的几部，可能更多，不擅长做调查。他为多部热门动画电影的角配过音。但你认识并喜爱他是因为他最近在幕后作为编剧、制片人以及三部不可思议电影的硬核导演的工作，
two of which we've seen. These have yielded four Academy Award nominations and one win. His new film will undoubtedly add to all of that because it looks triple good. Or as the kids like to say dope, which rhymes with nope, which is the name of the film.
其中两部我们看过。这些作品为他赢得了四项奥斯卡提名和一次获奖。他的新电影无疑会为这一切增添光彩，因为它看起来超级棒。或者正如孩子们喜欢说的“绝（nope）”，这也是电影的名字。
Here's Jordan Peele! No way! Look at that. No one's ever taken a bow, you guys. Wow. You took a bow like the opposite way. Your head went way up. I took a bow on an audio podcast.
这位是乔丹·皮尔！不会吧！看那。从没有人鞠过躬，伙计们。哇。你鞠躬的方式反过来了。你的头抬得老高。我在一个音频播客里鞠躬了。
Jordan, I was just talking about you today. Don't choke the puppy. Just ease off. I was just talking about him today. I had to just say that. Here I am in the flesh. I'm very excited that you're here. This is so exciting.
乔丹，我今天刚提到你。别把小狗勒死了。放松点。我今天刚提到他。我不得不这么说。我真真切切地坐在这里。我很高兴你来到这里。这太令人兴奋了。
It's so exciting to meet you. We're going to get to it, but it's like the number one movie I'm most excited to see. I watched the trailer a half a dozen times. I've seen the trailer a million times. That's fantastic. I've seen the clicks that you've put on the YouTube trailer.
见到你太令人兴奋了。我们要进入正题了，但这部电影简直是我最期待看的头号电影。我把预告片看了好几遍。我看过这个预告片一百万遍了。太棒了。我看到了你在YouTube预告片上获得的点击量。
He's got a lock on our IP address. Thank you. While we're talking about the trailer here, do you cut your own trailers? Or do you have meaningful consultation? I love that phrase. Or do you let the fine folks at Universal get it all done and vendor that stuff out?
他锁定了我们的IP地址。谢谢。在我们谈论预告片的时候，你会自己剪辑预告片吗？还是会有意义深远的协商？我喜欢那个短语。或者你让环球影业的好心人们把这一切搞定，然后把那部分外包出去？
Because the trailers for your films are equally incredible. You can't use vendor as a verb. Don't say vendor that stuff out. That's one of the grossest things. But you just tried to slide in there, and it's one of the most disgusting things. And a fucking long list of just...
因为你的电影预告片同样令人难以置信。你不能把“外包（vendor）”当动词用。别说把那部分外包出去。那是让人最恶心的事情之一。但你刚才试图把它滑过去，这是最令人作呕的事情之一。还有一长串令人发指的……
Can I talk to you for a second? Yes. I'm really nervous. Guys, whenever you're ready, I can. Hey, man, we're back. So we're talking trailers? Did you get your hands on that at all? Well, yeah, man.
我能跟你说句话吗？可以。我真的很紧张。伙计们，你们什么时候准备好，我都可以。嘿，伙计，我们回来了。所以我们在聊预告片？你插手过那件事吗？嗯，是的，伙计。
I think a lot of directors are envious of the trailers that I get to put out. And I have to give Universal marketing just a lot of credit. They bring just great work and they're collaborative. We've had success from Get Out.
我认为很多导演都很嫉妒我能推出的预告片。我必须给环球影业的营销团队极大的赞誉。他们带来的作品非常棒，而且他们很有合作精神。从《逃出绝命镇》开始我们就一直很成功。
Right. So they'll let you poke around. Oh, yeah, they'll let me poke around. They'll let me poke around. In the very beginning, we had to make some strong decisions. In Get Out, the whole question of do you let out that rose
对。所以他们会让你四处插手。哦，是的，他们会让我四处插手。他们会让我在里面瞎逛。在最初的时候，我们必须做出一些艰难的决定。在《逃出绝命镇》中，整个问题是，你是否要让大家知道罗斯——
that the evil white girl, that the white girl is evil, do you let that out? Is that the thing that's going to bring the evil white girl movie? Okay, well, now I have to see the evil white girl movie. And so we together chose not to do that and we made the right choice, I think.
那个邪恶的白人女孩，那个白人女孩是邪恶的，你是否要把它透露出去？这是不是那个会毁了邪恶白人女孩电影的东西？好吧，现在我必须去看那部邪恶白人女孩的电影了。所以我们一起选择不这么做，我认为我们做出了正确的选择。
But it meant that you couldn't really put a certain section of the film in the materials, right? Yeah, that's right. But it was worth it. It was the right move. Get Out is also one of my favorite movies of all time. Well, thank you.
但这意味著你不能真的把电影的某一部分放进宣传材料里，对吧？对，没错。但这是值得的。这是正确的举动。而且《逃出绝命镇》也是我史上最喜欢的电影之一。嗯，谢谢你。
And I love it, so I've seen it a million times. No, it's fine. But if that number just pops up. Yeah, that number is just fucking, that's it. Yeah, no, we have it on record. That was your first movie you ever directed? First movie ever? First movie ever.
我太喜欢它了，所以我看过一百万遍了。不，没关系。但如果那个数字突然冒出来。对，那个数字他妈的，就是这样。对，没错，我们有记录。那是你导演的第一部电影？有史以来第一部电影？有史以来第一部电影。
And how did that happen? Because it's flawless. Oh, stop. And it wins an Academy Award for writing it. I know. You guys, you got too much. Did you have a sit down with yourself or with someone else you probably would say,
这怎么可能发生？因为它是完美的。哦，别这样。而且它还赢得了奥斯卡最佳编剧奖。我知道。伙计们，你们太夸张了。你有没有和自己坐下来谈谈，或者和别人聊聊，你可能会说，
now, baby, you're probably going to witness for the next 20, 30 years is just a rapid descent from the peak of the, like, how could it ever get better? Were you prepared for just like, it's too much too soon? And then you went ahead and doubled it
现在，宝贝，你在接下来的20、30年里见证的可能只是从顶峰的急剧下滑，像，怎么可能变得更好？你准备好迎接这种“盛名之下其实难副”的感觉了吗？然后你接着把它翻倍了，
with us, probably tripled it with, I mean, just look at it though. Probably. Well, thank you. No, I mean, yeah, dude, it was so much pressure yet at the same time, you know, so many opportunities opened up because of that thing and literally the opportunity
跟我们比，可能翻了三倍，我是说，看看就知道了。可能吧。好吧，谢谢。不，我是说，是的，伙计，压力太大了，但与此同时，你知道，因为那个东西打开了太多的机会，字面意义上的机会，
to say, okay, what story, you know, to be able to write something knowing it's going to get made is a whole different thing. Right, yeah. And that it's got to be at least as good because they're going to be waiting for you to be a one hit wonder. Right.
就是说，好吧，什么故事，你知道的，能够写一部明知会被拍成电影的东西，完全是另一回事。对，没错。而且它必须至少同样好，因为他们会在一旁等着看你是不是昙花一现。对。
And then like all of that pressure to still let your creativity come through without having it be muted and angled by that pressure. How did you push through that? You know, you embrace the risk that only you can take, because that's really the position you're at.
然后还要承受所有那些压力，让你的创造力流露出来，而不被那种压力所消音和扭曲。你是怎么挺过来的？你知道，你要拥抱只有你才能承担的风险，因为这确实是你所处的位置。
You have more leeway, so you have to take a big gobble of risk and do something you're kind of not supposed to do each time. And that was us. And that was us to me at the time. You swung and you nailed it. Thank you, man. Thank you.
你有更多的回旋余地，所以你必须大口大口地承担风险，每次都做一些你本不该做的事情。这就是我们。对当时的我来说就是这样。你放手一搏，而且成功了。谢谢你，伙计。谢谢。
I'm so proud of these movies. I'm so proud of this movie. I'm about to unleash on the world. When does it come out? When does it come out? It comes out the 22nd. 22nd of July. So this might be right around that time.
我为这些电影感到骄傲。我为这部即将向全世界发布的电影感到骄傲。它什么时候上映？什么时候上映？22号上映。7月22日。所以这可能刚好就在那个时候左右。
Jordan, I want to say, let me ask you this question. You know, obviously, I think one of the most trailblazing TV shows of the last 25 years, you guys wrote some unbelievable sketches on that show that are still memorable
乔丹，我想说，让我问你这个问题。你知道，显然，我认为过去25年来最具开创性的电视剧之一，你们在那部节目中写了一些令人难以置信的小品，至今令人难忘，
that I still go and look at today. And I'm not one of those people who constantly goes like, hey, you know, brings up bits that other people do for whatever reason, but your sketches from that show for me have been a touchstone of really funny,
我今天仍然会去看。我不是那种经常说，嘿，你知道的，不管出于什么原因提起别人做过的段子的人，但你节目中的小品对我来说一直是真正搞笑、真正原创的试金石。我喜欢——我是说，我在这一点上并不独特——但我喜欢真正原创的喜剧，你们创作了令人难以置信的原创喜剧。
really original. I love, I mean, I'm not unique in that way, but I love really original comedy and you guys did incredible original comedy. And how much writing of that do you think prepared you for this next chapter that you're in now?
你觉得其中有多少写作经验为你现在所处的下一个篇章做好了准备？
Writing sketch because it's such a discipline, right? Because I think all of us are like, we love you from, just to piggyback on what Will says, we all obviously love you from key and peel and everything you've done before Get Out. So when Get Out came out, we're like, wait, what? But it's not surprising because you wrote some great sketches. No, not the talent.
写小品，因为这是一种极其严格的纪律，对吧？因为我认为我们所有人都觉得，我们爱你——顺便呼应一下威尔的话——我们显然都非常喜欢你在《基和皮尔》以及你在《逃出绝命镇》之前做过的一切。所以当《逃出绝命镇》上映时，我们都在想：等等，什么？但这并不令人意外，因为你写过一些很棒的小品。不，不是说才华。
Was that like a training ground, do you think? Did that sort of give you a kind of discipline? To be good, fast? Yeah, I mean, fuck, yeah. You know, the sketch to me is about a couple of things that I think the movies are also about. And with sketch
你觉得那就像是一个训练营吗？那是否赋予了你某种纪律？为了快速变得优秀？是的，我是说，他妈的，是的。你知道，在我看来，小品关乎几件事，我认为电影也关乎这些。通过小品，
you get this, one of the things you get is a great training ground for just that, getting to sort of push the boundaries and understand audience. And you get to commit to something just for three minutes at a time and sometimes you take too big a swing,
你得到了这个，你得到的其中一件事就是一个极佳的训练营，专门用来突破界限并理解观众。而且你每次只需全情投入三分钟，有时你步子迈得太大，
sometimes you don't take big enough a swing, but you get calibrated in that whole, in what to swing for, right? And so I think a lot of what I think makes one of my movies, one of my movies is that you know, from the early stages
有时你步子迈得不够大，但你会在整个过程中校准，明确该为什么而奋斗，对吧？所以我认为我的电影之所以能成为我的电影，很大程度上是因为你知道，从早期阶段
and every stage through I am trying to think of how can that how can I take a risk? What is the right risk to take here? Because that's what people need. That's what people really deserve is something that's fucking sketchy to do and to pull off
到之后的每一个阶段，我都在思考：我该如何冒险？这里要冒的正确风险是什么？因为这正是人们所需要的。人们真正应得的是一些他妈的很大胆、很难做到且需要说服工作室让你去尝试的东西，必须是那样的。
and to convince the studio to let you do has to be that. Well, like a lot of your sketches you guys would take a kernel of an idea and you would keep doubling down on it and keep heightening it in a way that was like, and you were like, oh fuck these guys now they're heightening it again
就像你的很多小品一样，你们会抓住一个核心想法，然后不断加码，不断将其推向高潮，这种方式就像是，你会想，“哦，操，这些家伙现在又在加码了，”
which is just the nature of really good comedy, right? Well this is you guys, you know this is these are the rules that all you guys fucking do every day, you know these things and yeah, it felt a bit, there was a vacuum there for a minute where it felt like
这正是真正优秀喜剧的本质，对吧？好吧，这就是你们，你们知道的，这就是你们所有人每天都在做的那套规则，你们懂这些，是的，感觉有点，当时有那么一分钟出现了一个真空期，感觉就像是，
you know, we've had these great sketch shows that come along and just and live in color and Mr. Show, Chapelle, you know you have these moments where these things happen that's different and it hadn't happened for a while. So then you get into writing Get Out
你知道，我们曾有过这些伟大的小品秀，像《活色生香》（In Living Color）、《罗宾·威廉姆斯秀》（Mr. Show）、《查佩尔秀》（Chappelle），你知道，你会经历这些时刻，这些不同的事情发生了，而且已经很久没有发生了。然后你开始写《逃出绝命镇》，
which is just comes you know, just absolute like a freight train just man just hits everybody and it just part really becomes just part of the for a while there just it was the it thing culturally in that movie
它就像，你知道的，绝对像一辆货运列车一样向你袭来，伙计，震撼了所有人，它在一段时间内真正成为了文化上的焦点，那部电影
really, really grab people and again though I was going to say like you kind of use the same principles, right? Like you just kept doubling down on the idea and you kept pushing it out further you talked about that before like how far can I push this idea
真的很深地抓住了人们的心，不过我刚才想说的是，你有点在运用相同的原则，对吧？就像你不断在那个想法上加码，你不断把它推得更远，你之前谈到过这个，我能把这个想法推多远，
what more can I do and surprise people I think that's it it's the element of surprise. Yeah, how did you think what I mean you've been asked this a million times and forgive me I don't know the answer but every time I watch Get Out and like I said one million times how did you think how
我还能做些什么来给人们带来惊喜，我认为这就是关键，也就是惊喜的元素。是的，你怎么想——我是说这个问题你已经被问过一百万遍了，原谅我，我不知道答案，但每次我看《逃出绝命镇》时，就像我说的，那第一百万遍，你是怎么想的——
I mean it's such a bizarre brilliant concept. Wow, where did you get the idea? The idea you know honestly it's just it's life right I mean there's this that there's this group of wealthy people that buy body parts I mean it's so not yeah well
我是说，这是一个如此离奇又 brillante（精彩）的概念。哇，你是怎么想出这个主意的？这个主意，说实话，这就是生活，对吧？我是说，有一群富人购买身体部位，这太不可思议了，好吧，
the whole thing started with just that feeling okay if I can if I can capture a feeling, a horror a fear that I haven't seen bottled in a film before if I can identify that fear I can make
整件事最初只是源于那种感觉：好吧，如果我能捕捉到一种感觉，一种我在电影里从未见过的恐惧，如果我能识别出那种恐惧，我就可以以此拍一部恐怖片，
a horror movie out of it because it's there right just the way in sketch comedy if you get it if one thing you say can get a laugh I know all you guys if you get a laugh once you can get it a million times and you can keep getting it you know how to do that. Just say sashimi
因为它就在那里，对吧？就像在小品喜剧中，如果你懂的话，如果你说的某句话能引发笑声，我知道你们所有人，如果你能让别人笑一次，你就能让他们笑一百万遍，而且你可以不断让他们笑，你知道该怎么做。只要说生鱼片（sashimi）
yeah yeah a million times yeah and then same kind of thing I was like I know this nugget of I am this fear of being in the most the black guy in a white space
对，对，一百万遍，对，然后也是类似的情况，我想我知道这种核心感觉：我是白人空间里唯一的黑人那种恐惧，
where you're feeling feeling the attention and it's not good even if it feels even if it's supposed to be a nugget and it's this thing that I know that everyone recognizes in their own way but so anyway so it started with like that
你在那里感受到了关注，而且这种关注并不好，即使它感觉起来、即使它本该是个核心亮点，而且这是我深知每个人都以自己的方式认同的东西。所以不管怎样，所以它始于类似那场派对的序列，就像是，好吧，这就是那部电影。
party sequence in a way was like okay that's the movie yeah but there's a there's an element to what you do that you would assume could only really happen after a lot
但你所做的事情中有一种元素，你可能会认为只有在经历了大量的练习和对电影制作过程的大量接触之后才能真正发生，那就是营造一种令人不安的环境的能力，
of practice and a lot of exposure to the filmmaking process and that is this ability to create an unsettling environment and there's there's a camera component to that there's a sonic component to that an editorial pace to that
这里面有摄像机的成分，有声音的成分，有剪辑节奏的成分，有灯光的成分，你是在哪里找到并学会这一切的？我是说，从一开始的《逃出绝命镇》，晚上街头的那场戏，里面有那么多的耐心，你当时就觉得，我简直紧张得要命，
there's a lighting component to that where did you find all of that and learn all of that I mean right out of the gate and get out the scene on the street at night there was so much patience that you it was like I'm already
因为事情没有……我想，那是一个长镜头吗？我想，是的，我是说——就像你是怎么做到这一点的？如果你注意的话，这是一开场就有的。你当时受到了你雇佣的摄影指导（DP）的鼓励吗？还是说，这只是因为你是个大佬？你还在吗，崔西？抱歉，
nervous out of my mind because things aren't I think was it a runner I think that yeah I mean like where do you where do you get off doing that right if you're paying attention it's one right out of the gate were you encouraged
这就是你谈到崔西时用的某种商业行话吗？有那个因素，但也有……他在为我冗长的问题道歉，我也确实很啰嗦。肖恩的姐姐住在威斯康星州，她叫崔西，所以我们总是向崔西解释，DP是摄影指导（director of photography）的意思，一镜到底（oneer）……DP可以指摄影指导，对。崔西，你自己去查那些狗屁东西吧，崔西，去查查。
by a DP that you hired were you or is it just you're just a baller are you there are you still with us Tracy sorry is that what you talk about Tracy when some kind of business jargon there's that but then there's also
所以你从哪里学到了所有这些电影制作的天赋，这可能是最经济的问法。谢谢你，多么可爱的问题。是看电影，看电影。顺便说一句，我最初是个木偶师，我上大学时以为自己会做那种工作。
he's apologizing for my long-winded questions which I am Sean's sister lives in Wisconsin and her name is Tracy and so we always explain to Tracy DP means cinematographer and oneer is DP can mean cinematographer yeah Tracy look up that shit yourself Tracy look it up
这太疯狂了，拜托。是的，完全是关于这种我当时觉得挺美丽、挺特别、却注定要没落的艺术形式，虽然你不会在它上面真正失败，但整个概念
so where do you get all of this filmmaking talent is probably the better economical way to ask it thank you what a lovely question it's watching movies it's watching movies and by the way like I started as a puppeteer as what I went to college thinking
就是这种幻觉，对吧？然后从那以后，我演过戏，写过剧本，做过很多事。我在其他领域有过很好的经历。你从哪里开始的？玩木偶戏听起来好难，因为你必须一直把胳膊举着，
I was gonna do something like that that's crazy come on yeah this totally on this sort of vanquish art form that I thought was kind of beautiful and special can't really fail at it but the whole notion is
或者垂着，无所谓，只要把自己垫高一点，你可以让它们稍微垂下来一点。肖恩，天哪，你从哪里开始的？那是什么情况，乔丹？我都不知道你扯到哪儿去了。我当年去莎拉劳伦斯学院的时候，有点像我对我的专业是什么给出的时髦的文科院校式的回答：我是一个木偶师。
this illusion right and then since then I've just I've acted I've written I've done a lot I just had a great experience in the other pieces where did you start puppeteering seems so hard because you have to keep your arms up
这太酷了。雕塑课、戏剧课，你知道的，我当时就像个真正的不羁的木偶师，在莎拉劳伦斯学院。
or down it doesn't matter just elevate yourself and you can hang them down a little bit Sean god where did you start where was that going on Jordan I don't even know where you go when I went to Sarah Lawrence kind of like my cheeky in like a liberal arts college
女孩们只需要听到这些就够了吧？对，他他妈是个什么人，他是个干什么的，他用他的双手在做什么？但那种自信是从哪里来的呢？你如何确信自己能够带领观众，从一个看起来相当正常的事物，
answer to what my major was was I'm a puppeteer that's so cool sculpture, theater classes you know I was like real real bohemian puppeteer at Sarah Lawrence
过渡到一个不正常的事物？你显然在喜剧中知道怎么做，对吧？因为你得先表现得好像“我们只是你们普通人”，然后我们做一件有点让人意外的事情，随之而来的笑声中带着惊喜。
that's all the girls needed to hear right yeah he's a fucking what he's a what he does what with his hands but where does the confidence come to trust that you're going to be able to transition an audience from something that seems fairly normal
拍恐怖片也是这样吗？这也是同一种计算吗？恐怖片，是的，是的，对，对，对。恐怖片是相通的，我知道你，我知道你在你自己的作品中也玩弄过这一点。
into something that is abnormal you obviously know how to do that in comedy right because you got to sort of present as just well we're just you and then we do something that's a little bit on that's surprising and then there's the surprise that comes with the laugh
我总是发现恐怖和喜剧是彼此交织在一起的，因为它们都关乎尽可能地将荒谬感落地。两者都是在进行一次豪赌，要么让你他妈的感到恐惧，要么让你以某种方式感到荒谬，并且把它变得真实。而两者的区别可能就在于两段音乐的不同。
is it the same kind of thing with doing horror is it the same kind of calculation what a horror yes yes yeah yeah with horror it is connected and you know I know you I know you play around with this
我只想让你知道，我不知道你知不知道，我不知道你知不知道我是加拿大人，他们在加拿大改了你的电影的名字，《逃出绝命镇》在加拿大叫《逃出绝命镇》（Get Out）——好吧，太棒了，伙计们，你们——罗布·贝内特，你们在拍这些东西吗？他们才不会把它剪掉呢，你这个混蛋。
in your own work there's a rhythm I always find that horror and comedy are sort of baked into one another because it's about grounding and absurdity as best as possible both both is taking a swing to something that is either going to make you
不，不，我只是想确保我们录下来了。我想确保我们录下了这个。他们是用两个O和一个T拼出来的吗，威尔，为了把这个笑话讲完？哦，抱歉，杰森，你在问乔丹关于灯光套餐的事吗，你这个混蛋？
fucking you know terrified or make you absurd in some way and making it real and the difference can be the difference between two pieces of music I was just going to let you know I don't know if you know this I don't know if you know that I'm Canadian
开始啦。我不知道我刚才在说什么。我不知道是什么。我们也不知道。我们马上回来。
and they changed your movie the title get out in Canada they called it get out okay that's great guys you again Rob Bennett are you guys are rolling on all this stuff they're not going to cut that out you dick no no I just want to make sure we got that I want to make sure we got that
现在回到节目。话说回来，当你构思这些原创点子的时候——因为它们每一个都像是令人难以置信的前提和概念——是因为唐娜·兰利（Donna Langley）和彼得·克雷默（Peter Kramer）在环球影业太聪明、太有魄力了，
do they spell it two O's and a T Will just to finish the joke oh sorry Jason what are you asking Jordan about the lighting packages you fucking dick here we go I don't know what I was saying I don't know what it was we don't either
所以他们说“太棒了，去吧”，还是你得用一堆花招去说服他们，让他们别担心这会很商业化？就像真正的问题一样。对，我是说，你怎么能……它们是原创点子，而你却能让这家主流电影公司资助一个并不是那种套路化概念的东西？
and we will be right back and now back to the show now when you come up with these original ideas because none of them are like it's incredible premises and concepts is it because Donna Langley and Peter Kramer
我有同样的问题，你知道，我们遇到过几次他们愿意承担风险并最终得到回报的情况。对于这部电影，我感到非常非常被信任，你知道，我和那些人说话的方式……我听到这个了，你听起来很棒，你听起来真他妈酷。
are so darn smart and courageous at Universal that they're saying yeah great go or are you having to do a bunch of tricks to talk them into don't worry this is going to be commercial like the real questions yeah I mean how do you they're original ideas and you're getting
你可卖不出像威尔·阿奈特那样的皮卡，你听起来沙哑。我听起来像韦恩（Weezy），韦恩。但我的意思是，他们给了我很大的回旋余地，让我在电影里搞了一些疯狂的鬼把戏。
this major studio to fund you know something that's not kind of boilerplate concept I had the same question you know we've had a couple of situations where they've taken on the risk
但在这所有这些粘稠的、有趣的爆米花式的内容背后，也有这些高雅的主题。我是说，你把这一切都处理得很好。这究竟是怎么发生的，杰森，快说。
and it's paid off you know for this one I felt very very trusted and you know the way I talk to those guys is I sound I hear this you sound great you sound fucking cool
是不是口水太多了？你的嫉妒心暴露了。不，这是反常现象。我正想问你关于切尔西的事。我也认识切尔西，你和切尔西是怎么认识的？我们在网上认识的。
you're not going to sell pickup trucks like Will Arnett you sound raspy I sound like Weezy Weezy but I mean they gave me a lot of leeway to do some crazy shit in the movie
我在听了她的播客后给她发了私信，我看到她做了一些单口喜剧，我基本上就给她发了私信，就是这样，挺酷的，有时这招挺管用的。
but there's these highbrow themes underneath all of this sticky you know fun popcorn stuff too I mean you're doing it all good how does it happen Jason real quick
直接私信就能加载出帕雷迪（Paredi）。你能告诉我们你有多大吗？你有一个小男孩还是小女孩？我有一个男孩叫波。我们现在能看出他是聪明的还是笨的吗？
is there too much drool your jealousy is showing no it's aberration I was going to ask you about Chelsea so I know Chelsea as well and how did you guys how did you and Chelsea meet? we met on the internet
他非常聪明，他喜欢阅读，他是个天才。哇，他已经比杰森聪明了，我敢肯定。我们有一些共同的缺点，这么说吧。他的缺点，我意识到……告诉我你擅长什么。
I DMed her after I heard her on a podcast I saw her and do some stand up and I was basically DMed her and it was that's cool sometimes it works
我他妈不擅长什么？我非常不擅长保持东西清洁。我只是看到某个人然后就会走神，活在我妻子的世界之外，你就会直接放空。是的，我会试着……
load up Paredi on the straight DMs can you tell you how old you have a young boy or girl I got a boy named Bo can we tell yet whether he's a smart one or a dumb one
这就是那种情况，你跟你的儿子说话，就叫波，波，然后什么反应都没有。我意识到我也会做同样的事情。我发现他会喊十次“爸爸”，而我在想：也许这只是专注，这只是集中精神，这只是纪律。
he's a very smart he's a reader he's a brilliant wow he's smarter than Jason already I'm sure we share some faults let's put it that way his faults I realized tell me what you're bad at
我就是这么想的。亚历山德罗不久前刚告诉我——我甚至快记不起那是什么了，但我问了她一个问题，她说：“我在过去的24小时里已经把答案告诉你四遍了。”那是她的姓氏吗？我也是这样。
what am I shit at I'm really bad at keeping things clean I just see somebody and just being and spacing out being on my wife's existence you'll just check out yeah and I'll try and
为什么我们都这样？这就是演员，他妈的。我们都是笨蛋，我们都活在自己的脑子里。我的记忆力只为背台词而工作，就这样。好吧，等等，等一下。我不知道我们还有多少时间。
it's one of these things you're talking to your son just Bo Bo and just nothing and I realize I'll do the same thing I realize he'll be saying dad 10 times and I'm like maybe that's just concentration and that's focus and that's discipline
我只是想回应杰森，是的，先生，你刚才说了非常nice的话。但我想说的是，我不知道这有多被强调，但你绝对是……伙计们，让他说完，听起来这可能是一个恭维。
that's what I think is happening I had Alessandro just told me very recently that I was getting to remember again what it was but I asked her something and she goes I've told you the answer to this like four times in the last 24 hours was it her last name? I'm the same way
你绝对是我这辈子见过的第一个用这种干巴巴的语气表演的喜剧演员！我这辈子见过的第一个！第一个干巴巴的！我以前从来没见过。我说的是他妈的霍根——哇，霍根家族。
why are we all that way this is actors motherfucker we're all dumb asses we're all inside our head my memory works just for learning lines that's it okay wait hold on a second I don't know how much time we have
我们稍微倒回一点。说到看到——兄弟，我们在聊霍根。好吧，这有点像是——对，这有点像是爱丽丝·P·基顿（Alice P. Keaton）那种宇宙，你有这个，你知道的，迈克尔·贾格（Michael Jag）到处乱跳，但你带着这种节奏出场了，
I just want to respond to Jason yes sir you're very nice things but I want to say I don't know how much it's stressed but you are the first guys let him finish this sounds like it might be a compliment
我发誓这是最棒的，以前有过这种节奏吗，乔丹？太他妈棒了。JB的，我们来谈谈JB，小小的恭维，他妈的，后来者都在模仿，他妈的有人来模仿。
you are the first fucking dry delivery comedy guy I've ever seen in my life I've ever seen in my life first dry I've never seen it before I'm talking about fucking Hogan wow Hogan family
他们都在模仿。我当时偷了太多——杰森真的发明了这一点，当它成为一件大事的时候。我跟你说，还记得我当时有多生气吗，因为我在想：那是他妈的贝特曼的风格！我看到这些混蛋在其他节目里用它，在广告里把它当成搞笑的点睛之笔，
let's go back a bit talking about seeing bro we're talking about Hogan okay this is coming out of like right this is coming out of an Alice P. Keaton sort of universe where you got this you know Michael Jag jump around but you came in
而他们却像是在说“真的吗？”，而我在想：那是贝特曼他妈的发明的！我们在《发展受阻》（Arrested Development）里做过这招。我在模仿他，我当时就是在模仿他。同时，还有一件事，我第一次见杰森时，我们正在试拍《发展受阻》的试播集，这是我最喜欢的
with this cadence that I swear it's the best has it ever happened before Jordan it's so fucking good JB's let's go on JB little compliment motherfuckers copied and motherfuckers came and copied
一个如此愚蠢的笑话。我们在排练厅里，这家伙进来了，他是个剧务，浑身都是纹身，脖子上、手上，所有人，到处都是纹身。他径直走到我们面前，开始跟某个人说话，杰森用全音量——因为他不
they all copied I was stealing too many Jason invented really when that became a big thing I'm telling you and remember how mad I got about that because I was like that's fucking Bateman's and I'd see these motherfuckers doing it on other shows and doing it as punchlines in commercials
知道那家伙知不知道谁是老大，谁才是真正的大佬——我他妈直接倒在地上，我都哭了。是的，我一辈子都在试图模仿比尔·默瑞（Bill Murray），对吧，或者约翰·克里斯（John Cleese），
and they're like really and I'm like that's Batman fucking invented and we did it on a recipe I was copying him I was copying him meanwhile here's the other thing when I first met Jason we were throwing the pilot for rest development this is one of my favorite
或者本·斯蒂勒（Ben Stiller）。但效果没那么好，效果没那么好。我从来没觉得那完全够用，所以我拿过来，真正把它的档次提升了。你确实这么做了，你在上面穿上了踢踏舞鞋。
it's such a dumb joke we're in this rehearsal hall and this guy comes in he's a crew guy and he's covered in tats the neck, hands, everybody just covered and he walked in like right in front of us and kind of like started talking to somebody and Jason full volume because he wasn't
对，我穿上了踢踏舞鞋，而且我当时觉得没有人会注意到——这行不通的，所以我真的用那个震撼了房间的后方。但它确实，它是值得注意的。你太好了，谢谢。你之前提到过，不仅是《逃出绝命镇》，《不！》（Nope）以及你所有的很多灵感都来自于你看过的电影。
knew that the guy wouldn't know who's your top dog who's your tippy and I fucking I fell to the ground I was crying yeah I've just been trying to do Bill Murray my whole life right or John Cleese
我知道那家伙不会知道谁是老大 谁又是顶尖人物 然后我他妈的 我倒在地上哭了 是啊 我一辈子都在模仿比尔·莫瑞或者约翰·克里斯
or Ben Stiller it didn't hit like that it didn't hit like that I never thought it was quite enough so I took it and just really notched it up you did you put tap shoes on it
或者本·斯蒂勒 但感觉不对 感觉就是不对 我从来没觉得那完全足够 所以我接受了并把它大大提升了 你确实给它穿上了踢踏舞鞋
yeah I put tap shoes on and I didn't think nobody it's not going to read so I just really hit the back of the room with that but it is it's worth it's worthy of nothing you're very nice thank you you had mentioned that a lot of the inspiration for not only Get Out but Nope and all of your stuff is from movies you've seen
对啊 我穿上了踢踏舞鞋 我觉得没人 会看懂这一点 所以我真的用那个震撼了全场 但这确实 值得一提 你太好了 谢谢你 你曾提到过 不仅是《逃出绝命镇》 还有《不！》以及你所有的作品 很多灵感都来自你看过的电影
what are your inspirations what movies do you draw upon and do you are stuck in your head as inspirations yeah who's done it really really well that you're dying to do it as good as I would say you have no equal but like who's been pulling you and hopefully there's a compliment but just from the trailer
你的灵感来自哪里 你借鉴了哪些电影 哪些会一直盘旋在你脑海中成为灵感 是啊 谁能把这个拍得极其出色 以至于你恨不得自己也能拍得那么好 我会说你无人能及 但就像 谁一直在吸引着你 希望这是一个赞美 但仅从预告片来看
of Nope I'm like oh it's very M Night but now I go oh it's very Jordan Peele oh thank you I'm a big M Night fan I think he's one of the greats I love I'm kind of a it's kind of a boring answer because I
对于《不！》，我的感觉是“哦，这很有奈沙马兰的风格”，但现在我觉得“哦，这非常有乔丹·皮尔的风格”。哦，谢谢你。我是奈沙马兰的超级粉丝，我觉得他是最伟大的人之一。我喜欢……这算是一个有点无聊的回答，因为我
like Kubrick and Spielberg and Hitchcock that's the one and Tito I'm joking I'm being glib but I like what people go I don't know I mean for me I like the Beatles oh do you
喜欢库布里克、斯皮尔伯格和希区柯克，就是那些，开玩笑的，我在瞎扯。但我喜欢当人们说——我不知道，对我来说，我喜欢披头士。哦，是吗？
oh you like the Beatles yeah yeah yeah well that's me while we're here my favorite Sean Hayes story did not know Beatles was spelt B-E-A-T no by the way just my favorite by the way penis lots of people no comments also agreed with me
哦，你喜欢披头士？对，对，对，好吧，正因如此，在我们聊到这儿的时候，我最喜欢的肖恩·海斯的故事是，他以前不知道披头士（Beatles）的拼写是 B-E-A-T，没有，顺便说一句，这只是我最喜欢的，顺便说一句，阴茎，很多人，没有评论，也同意我的看法。
I didn't know we were calling Bateman penis I didn't even know that that was a thing they're pity tweets wait wait so sorry Jordan you like Spielberg and you like Kubrick stuff that's cinematic stuff now that you put it like that fucking well I like fucking John
我不知道我们把贝特曼（Bateman）叫作阴茎，我甚至不知道还有这回事，那是些讽刺推文。等等，等等，抱歉，乔丹，你喜欢斯皮尔伯格，你喜欢库布里克的作品，那是电影感的东西。现在你这么一说，他妈的……好吧，我喜欢他妈的约翰……
I don't know I'm with you by the way I'm fucking with you so I'm just while we're there that cinematic tightens like those guys can you just indulge me for one second before we lose the audience about your pursuit and landing of Hoyta where that came from
我不知道，顺便说一句，我跟你是一伙的，我跟你开玩笑呢。所以，就在我们说到这儿的时候，像那些电影界的巨匠，他们能做到这一点——能不能请大家听我讲一秒钟，在我们失去观众之前，关于你是如何追求并签下霍伊特（Hoyt）的，这事是怎么谈成的？
this is a cinematographer like this guy's just nails how do you get well I tell you how you get him you make two great movies but like was it was it as incredible as you thought it would might be like I would imagine it would be
这是一个摄影师，这家伙简直牛透了。你是怎么搞定——我告诉你你是怎么搞定的：你拍了两部伟大的电影。但它——是不是像你想象的那么不可思议？因为我想象中这会是
different level right so I mean I've had I've worked with great cinematographers I've got I've gotten very lucky in all my films I mean with Hoyt I really got a guy who's done it all is that how you say it Hoyt it's he said Hoyt
不同的级别，对吧？所以，我的意思是，我合作过伟大的摄影师，我的所有电影都非常幸运。我是说，和霍伊特合作，我真的得到了一个无所不能的人。是这么叫的吗？霍伊特？他说的是霍伊特？
Hoyt Hoyt Hoyt Hoyt you can say it either way I say it either way I just never known he's a he's an absolute beast I mean he's just and what what we were able to do with this movie is push ground in ways that
霍伊特，霍伊特，霍伊特，霍伊特。你两种都可以叫，我两种都这么叫。我只是从来不知道……他绝对是个野兽。我的意思是，他简直……我们能用这部电影做到的是，在某种程度上开辟新的领域，
I don't even really want to talk about because I don't want to take some of the experience from the audience but you know we push technology with infrared cameras and he's just he yeah so we got on this it was just
我甚至不想多说，因为我不想剥夺观众的一部分体验。但你知道的，我们用红外摄像机推动了技术的发展，而他——他，是的，所以我们开始接触这个，这简直
like it's just exactly what you want as a director like this adventure where you're in over your head but you've got this salt of the earth fucking DP who knows it all who's like this guy's just Dutch guy this jolly
就像作为导演你梦寐以求的：这是一场冒险，你有些力不从心，但你拥有这个脚踏实地、无所不知的、地地道道的电影摄影师。就像这家伙是个荷兰人，这个快乐的
Dutch guy with his beard and he's like he's gonna be alright we're gonna figure this out by the way that's a good Dutch accent that's fucking great yeah I just like I don't know how do you gather when you have such a specific and unique flavor to your films how are you able to crew that and cast that appropriately
留着胡子的荷兰人，他说，他会没事的，我们会搞定这一切的。顺便说一句，那是个很好的荷兰口音，太他妈棒了。是的，我只是——我不知道，当你的电影具有如此独特和特有的风格时，你是如何聚集并为之挑选合适的剧组和演员的，
to where everybody is as crafty and clever as you are because they all just vendor it or do you just vendor it you vendor it because I have Apple pay but I'll take Venmo it's I mean you know the thing it's like the team building is the
好让每个人都像你一样手艺精湛、聪明绝顶？因为他们都接受维 Venmo 支付，还是你只是……你接受 Venmo 支付吗？因为我有 Apple Pay，但我也可以接受 Venmo。我的意思是，你知道吗，团队建设就是
thing if you get that part right it it really flows but um yeah you you just talk to people who for me I'm talking to people who are inspired by the idea and in a way that it's not you know in every
关键。如果你把这一部分做对了，一切就会顺理成章。但是，是的，你只是和那些——对年轻人来说，我在和那些受到这个创意启发的人交谈，而且在某种程度上，你知道，在每个
department it's not gonna be me telling saying this is what goes it's gonna be me about the collaboration between me and this person so if I'm excited about what they're excited about and maybe they're excited about something that I didn't even know to be excited about letting them do their thing we're going in that direction
部门里，不会都是我说了算，告诉他们该怎么做。这关乎我和这个人之间的合作。所以，如果我对他们感兴趣的东西感到兴奋，也许他们对一些我甚至不知道该感到兴奋的东西感到兴奋，让他们去做他们擅长的事，我们就会一起朝着那个方向前进。
together yeah did you did you so you touch on something really briefly in there when you were talking you said that you don't want to take away from people's experience and I don't know if I've had this experience myself I remember doing answering something questions
是的。你——所以你刚才在谈话中非常简短地提到了某件事，你说你不想夺走观众的体验，我不知道我自己是否有过这种经历。我记得几年前我们在做《马男波杰克》时回答过一些问题，我当时——我当时不想在这上面表现得太混蛋，我说，你知道，我觉得有时人们太过于强调
about when we were doing Bojack Horseman a few years ago and I kind of and I kind of didn't want to be too much of a dick about it and I said you know I feel like sometimes there's too much emphasis on you know how the sausage is made and not enough enjoying of the sausage
香肠是怎么制作的，而没有足够地去享受香肠。
and and I kind of got that feeling when you said that that it's like look I could talk ad nauseam about how I made this film and what kind of cameras and what kind of shots we did but you didn't do make the film so that you could explain that to the audience you did
当我听到你那么说时，我也有那种感觉：听着，我可以滔滔不绝地谈论我是如何拍这部电影的，用的是什么相机，我们拍了什么样的镜头。但你拍电影可不是为了向观众解释这些。你做了
all that shit and hopefully it's seamless and they don't know what that is and they just they experience it is that right that's right and you know the only the only reason I bring it up is to give white no you didn't bring it up yeah I'm dorking out yeah fair enough but but the but
所有这些狗屁东西，希望它是无缝衔接的，他们不知道那是什么，他们只是去体验它。是这样吗？完全正确。而且你知道，我提起这件事的唯一原因是为了给怀特——不，你没提起，是的，我在犯书呆子气，好吧，公平地说。但是——但是
the yeah I mean the the only reason I even tell you that there was some really interesting ground pushed at all so it is just so you know like yeah that hope to answer that question he's he's a real master yeah and
是的，我的意思是，我甚至告诉你这其中开辟了一些非常有趣的领域的原因，只是为了让你知道，是的，希望回答这个问题……他真的是个大师。对，而且
you again you didn't bring it up and obviously this is what we do and so we're asking the questions because we are and Jason's interested in our audiences too and I and Sean and I are really interested but I just mean more generally do you feel sometimes like you wish that you didn't have to answer
你又没有主动提起，显然这就是我们的工作，所以我们才会问这些问题，因为我们是，而且杰森对我们的观众也很感兴趣，我和肖恩也非常感兴趣。但我的意思是更广泛地说，你有时是否会希望你不必回答
questions about it and just let it the work speak for itself does that ever is that ever something that kind of annoys you or gets in the way you know I think it can get in the way and it was an interesting experience because I think with get out
关于这些的问题，而让作品自己说话？这会不会有时让你觉得烦恼或成为阻碍？你知道，我认为这确实会成为阻碍。这是一次有趣的经历，因为我认为对于《逃出绝命镇》，
you know it you know get out you know it had a lot of success but it was also there was a lot I was talking about it a lot yeah and and sort of trying to help that audience put together the dots on it and I don't know
你知道的，它取得了巨大的成功，但也有很多人在讨论它，我谈论了很多，是的，并且试图帮助观众把其中的线索串联起来。我不知道
if it needed that maybe not you know in the long run but to get people to see it and you know my entry point into film was sort of telling people what I did you know when it got to us you know all of a sudden we have something that is a bit of a vaguer notion of how to
它是否需要这些，也许从长远来看并不需要，但为了让人们去看它，你知道的，我进入电影界的切入点就是告诉别人我做了什么，你知道的，当它传到我们这里时，突然之间，我们有了一种更模糊的概念，不知道该如何
discuss and so I felt like the responsibility to that film was to not sort of take the audience through it but to let them experience it more you know I think with this film I'm gonna approach it letting the
讨论，所以我对那部电影的责任感不是引导观众去理解它，而是让他们更多地去体验它。你知道，我觉得对于这部电影，我将采取的方法是让
film lead a bit but you know I do want the audience to know it was about spectacle and that it was about the theatrical experience in its core in this idea of I felt like
电影本身起主导作用。但你知道，我确实希望观众知道，它是关于奇观的，其核心是关于剧院体验的，以及这种观念——我觉得
alright I've got this position I've got this responsibility to try and do that thing where I make some original shit that's just a fucking spectacle. The title cannot be beaten No better title for any film Can you tell us
好吧，我有了这个立场，我有了这种责任去尝试做那件事：拍一些纯粹是奇观的原汁原味的狗屁东西。片名无可挑剔。没有比这更好的电影名了。你能给我们
a little bit like just from a fan's point of view like I am like can you tell us a little bit about nope like can you tell us what the word nope means in the movie or what we're looking at in that trailer that they're looking at any kind of exciting anything Yeah I mean look
讲讲，就从粉丝的角度来看，就像我一样——你能给我们讲讲关于《不！》的一些事吗？比如，你能告诉我们“不”这个词在电影里意味着什么，或者我们在预告片里看到的他们正在看的东西是什么吗？任何激动人心的东西都可以。是的，我的意思是，听着，
it's I'll say this it's a word that's said a lot in the movie and it generally is something that you know part of the notion of this movie is like we got a big budget flying saucer movie
我会这么说：这是电影里经常说的一个词，它通常是——你知道，这部电影的一个理念是，我们拍了一部大预算的飞行器（飞碟）电影，
with black people in the lead that to me in itself you know there's no there's no need to really dig further in terms of how to push the conversation then there's a fucking do it right that should be
由黑人担任主角。对我来说，这本身，你知道的，就没必要在如何推动对话方面再深入挖掘了，直接他妈的拍出来就行了，对吧？这应该
that should just be on the one sheet by the way that's it right and well and then I mean it kind of is it's like the no part of it is I think an acknowledgement that you know it is a different movie you can't just make the same movie
这应该直接写在单页宣传单上，顺便说一句，就是这样，对吧？而且，我的意思是，它有点像那种感觉：其中的“不”部分，我认为是对以下事实的一种承认，你知道，这是一部不同的电影，你不能只是拍同一部电影，
you know and there is an experience that people want to see deal with this shit as well and you know I and I would also say it's a film that that feels like it's a concept
你知道的，人们也想看到一种能够应对这种烂摊子的体验，而且，你知道，我还要说的是，这是一部感觉像是一个概念的电影，
in a way but you know there is also an acronym to it that I think a lot of people online have sort of piece together well I think I know what it is you want to guess you go for it and you don't have to say yes or no not of planet earth
但在某种程度上，你知道，它也有一个首字母缩写，我想网上的很多人都已经把它拼凑出来了。哦，我想我知道那是什么。你想猜猜吗？尽管猜吧。你不需要说是或不是。不是来自星球地球（Not Of Planet Earth）。
well yeah did you just know that Will you're not that smart I thought you were going to say something funny and wrong not of planet earth it's pretty good but that was not funny and right wait how in the world did you I would have never
哦，是的！你怎么知道的？威尔，你没那么聪明。我以为你要说点有趣但错误的话。“Not Of Planet Earth”挺不错的，但那一点也不有趣，而且还猜对了。等等，你怎么会……我绝不会……
that's gotta be it well that's the end of the interview thanks so much I'm good at wordling that's pretty wild you sure are boy this guy alright now because of getting back to sort of your taste
那一定就是它了。好吧，采访到此结束，非常感谢。我很擅长玩 Wordle 游戏。这太疯狂了。你当然是，老兄。这家伙，好吧，现在因为要回到你的品味，
your radar for uniqueness and originality what are you watching what are you reading that keeps that sharp that keeps you kind of not postmodern but knowing where the next idea is going to come from
你对独创性和原创性的敏锐度，你在看什么，你在读什么来保持这种敏锐度，让你知道——不是后现代主义，而是知道下一个创意将从何而来，
that's going to make the last idea seem not so original it's a great question there's so much immersion into my own of my own ass that it's hard to you say you smoke a lot of weed
从而让上一个创意显得不那么原创？这是一个好问题。我有太多时间沉浸在自己的屁股里了，所以很难……你说你抽了很多大麻？
it's as simple as just getting the right strain of indica well I see what you're saying even when I'm fucking yes first of all yes when I'm coming up with shit that is kind of an important piece of the puzzle you know I like anime
这就像找到对的秲稻品种（indica）那么简单。哦，我明白你的意思了。甚至当我他妈的——首先，是的，当我构思那些相当重要的拼图碎片时，你知道，我喜欢动漫，
because anime is just high concept world building that is pulled off so well it's these big swings and there's it's a great way
因为动漫就是那种高概念的世界构建，完成得太棒了。这是这些巨大的转折，而且这是一个极好的方式，
to free yourself look you can tell a fucking crazy story and people do pull that shit off there are storytellers in the world that are pulling off really crazy things that are super popular that's one place
让你解放自己。看，你可以讲一个疯狂的故事，人们确实能做到这一点。世界上有讲故事的人正在讲述非常疯狂的事情，而且超级受欢迎，这是一个途径。
gotcha are you watching any comedy I find it hard to watch comedy I know it's broken I think it's probably broken for us where is it on television or is it on film right now
明白了。你在看什么喜剧吗？我发现很难看喜剧。我知道它坏了。我想它对我们来说可能已经坏了。它现在是在电视上还是在电影里？
or is it on stage, stand up where is funny shit happening some funny shit you know what's funny pen 15 is funny I just worked with Gabe Liedman who created that show I don't know
还是在舞台上、单口喜剧里？有趣的事情在哪里发生？一些有趣的事情——你知道什么有趣吗？《笔写青春》（Pen15）很有趣。我刚刚和创作那个节目的加布·利德曼（Gabe Liedman）合作过。我不知道，
I haven't seen shit but it is I do feel like we've been in this weird comedy drought where people want to laugh but somehow it's hard isn't it a lot like it's just become
我没看过什么好东西。但我确实觉得我们正处于这样一个奇怪的喜剧荒漠中，人们想笑，但不知为何却很难，不是吗？它只是变得
fragmented with tiktok and instagram where you can get your comedy filled through 5 second 10 second things so people are maybe not so inclined to go tune into an entire series I don't know just throwing that out there I have an idea
随着 TikTok 和 Instagram 的碎片化，你可以通过 5 秒、10 秒的内容来满足你的喜剧需求，所以人们可能没那么有兴致去收看一整部剧集了。我不知道，只是随口说说。我有个想法，
that from my own experience in dealing with streamers they tell us that they have a hard time getting people to stay through and watch multiple episodes in comedy it's really really really really difficult
根据我与流媒体合作的亲身经历，他们告诉我们，他们在让观众坚持看完喜剧的多集内容时遇到了困难，这真的、真的、真的、真的很难。
we'll be right back and now back to the show now is Chelsea a good sounding board for you reading pages or drafts or watching cuts of things and giving you good feedback
我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。现在，切尔西是你的一个好参谋吗？比如阅读剧本页或初稿，或者观看剪辑片段并给你提供好的反馈？
I know it's always tricky with a partner that little balance there I'm sure she's incredibly helpful but that's a dance right she is one of the reasons I love her she's always going to be honest
我知道和伴侣在一起总是很棘手，要把握好那个平衡。我确信她非常有帮助，但那是一支双人舞，对吧？她是我爱她的原因之一。她总是直言不讳，
and tell me the truth it's like there's a certain point in the industry where I'm sure you guys know there's nothing more attractive than that we're all lucky on this call here
对我说实话。就像在行业到了某个阶段，我确信你们俩也知道，没有什么比这更有吸引力的了。我们在这个电话连线里的所有人都是幸运的。
now what about it looked like you shot this thing in town here in Los Angeles in Santa Clarita perhaps as the website says by the way guys correct me if I'm wrong here Jordan
现在，关于这个——看起来你是在这里的镇上拍的，在洛杉矶，也许在圣克拉利塔（Santa Clarita），正如网站上所说的那样。顺便说一句，如果我弄错了请纠正我，乔丹，
this is the first time that a film has an amusement park there at Universal Studios tour being released germane to the movie on the same day the movie is being released
这是第一次有一部电影在环球影城之旅中拥有一个游乐设施，并且与电影上映的同一天向公众开放，这与电影息息相关？
usually a movie has to earn that by becoming super successful and then 4, 5, 6 years later they have like a ride he's got a you explain it Jordan but it's incredible what he's done here it's a big deal for me
通常一部电影必须通过变得超级成功来赢得这一点，然后 4、5、6 年后他们才会有这样一个游乐设施……你得解释一下，乔丹，但他在这里所做的一切真是不可思议。这对我很重要。
I'm in Universal Studios I remember going when I was 12 you see like fake it's like the experience like the fake version of what it means to make a movie it's like this is where Jaws was shot
我在环球影城，我记得我 12 岁去的时候，你看到那些假的——就像那种体验，什么是拍电影的假版本。就像“这是《大白鲨》拍摄的地方”，
it's like no it's not but it's like psycho house the whole like artifice that was Jason's backyard he played there when he was a kid no joke just do it
其实根本不是，但就像“惊魂记”的房子，整个那种虚假的布景——那是杰森的后院，他小时候在那里玩，不开玩笑，直接干吧。
silver spoons and it's your move Ricky would fart around back there on our bikes anyway so you know how when I went for the first time I was just blown away and so now we're on the lot now
银匙羹，轮到你了，里基会在我们自行车后面的那个地方瞎胡闹。无论如何，你知道吗，当我第一次去的时候，我简直惊呆了。所以现在我们回到了片场，
and just feel that magic again and yeah we've got Stephen Yin's character who is an amusement park called Jupiter's Claim and it's one of the centerpieces of the film and so that's going to be on the studio tour like fucking in between
再次感受那种魔法。是的，我们有史蒂文·元（Steven Yeun）的角色，他在那里经营一个叫“朱庇特寄售场”（Jupiter's Claim）的游乐园，这是电影的核心布景之一。所以它将出现在环球影城之旅中，他妈的就在
the psycho house and Jaws and is it sort of without giving away anything with the movie is the ride of this place is it kind of like a haunted house or a fun house like the website is
“惊魂记”的房子和《大白鲨》之间。而且，在不剧透电影的前提下，这个地方的游乐设施——它有点像鬼屋或游乐屋吗？就像那个网站一样，
that you can kind of click around on like all of the things on that tour there is going to be a certain amount of interactivity got it but the thing that real movie nerds are going to geek about
你可以在上面点来点去？就像那次游览中的所有东西一样，会有一定程度的互动。明白了。但是，真正狂热的电影迷会为之疯狂的一点，
upon the the hopeful embrace of this film is that it's there that's so cool they did that that is really really awesome now do you have to fly around and do a bunch of promotion for this or are you able to do it all with zoom
伴随着对这部电影的热切期待，就是它就在那里。太酷了，他们竟然这么做。这真的、真的太棒了。现在，你得飞来飞去为这部电影做一堆宣传，还是说你现在能通过 Zoom 完成这一切？
nowadays with the COVID or they got you on a world tour or something I'm going to do a tour they're going to cart me away to some places I'm just going to shut my eyes and open them and try to figure out where I am
现在因为新冠疫情，还是他们安排了你进行全球巡回宣传什么的？我要去巡回宣传。他们会把我用车推到一些地方。我只要闭上眼睛，然后睁开，试着弄清楚我在哪里，
and then do you like to take some down time before you start writing the next thing or are you already underway with that you know writing is kind of I mean it is the down time there's nothing more fun than being in those early stages of
然后，在开始写下一部作品之前，你喜欢花点时间休息一下，还是已经开始着手创作了？你知道，写作某种程度上——我的意思是，这就是休息时间。没有什么比处于那些早期阶段更有趣的了，
what is really the next one I mean it's a very relaxing if I'm doing it right it's a very freeing month you know do you want to like stay in the horror genre for a while or is there some kind of dream of like wanting to do something completely
那才是真正的下一部作品。我的意思是，这是一个非常放松的——如果我的做法正确的话，这是一个非常自由的月份。你知道的。你想在恐怖片领域多呆一段时间吗？还是说有什么梦想，比如想拍一部完全
you know left turn a musical one of the things that has been is fun for my journey in these first three films has been a little bit of the deconstruction of what I feel like
你知道的，大转弯式的电影，比如音乐剧？我拍前三部电影的旅程中，有趣的事情之一就是对以下内容的解构：
genre is and what the role of genre is in storytelling I love that I like this yeah you like this one so in that first one in that first one I was really using a very specific type of suspense thriller
什么是流派，以及流派在讲故事中扮演什么角色。我喜欢这个。你喜欢这个，是吧？所以在第一部中，在第一部里，我真的使用了一种非常特定类型的悬念惊悚片
genre trope and you know get out it fits in that world and so that helps the pieces of it I think that are outside of the box sing because there is a
流派套路，你知道，《逃出绝命镇》就属于那个世界。所以这有助于其中打破常规的部分脱颖而出，因为有一个
checkpoint there's a genre checkpoint that's genre I think you use very well at least for you know it worked so then you know us I really kind of focused on the horror idea you know and the specificness of no something a little bit more
检查点，一个流派检查点。我认为你对流派的运用非常出色，至少对你来说——它起作用了。所以然后，你知道的，我们——我真的很关注恐怖片的理念，你知道的，还有《不！》的独特性，某种对
threatening to the core of existence and scary in that way and in a lot of ways worked within that genre as well you know with this one I feel like this idea that's been bubbling in these other two films
存在核心更具威胁性、在这方面更可怕的东西。在很多方面，它也在那个流派中发挥作用。你知道，对于这部前两部电影中一直在酝酿的理念，
with no I think has come into fruition where I can't really pin it down to a genre anymore it kind of it is all things and I think I probably could do that
随着《不！》的推出，我认为它终于迎来了成果，我再也无法把它简单地归类为一个具体的流派了。它有点像包罗万象，我想我可能可以做到这一点。
you've kind of delved into a lot of bigger issues and I would suggest I didn't even think of get out as a horror movie at all and I'm saying horror I didn't think of it as a horror movie at all I thought of I mean it is I guess that's like a thriller yeah it's a thriller
你深入探讨了很多更大的议题，我会说——我甚至根本不认为《逃出绝命镇》是一部恐怖电影，我说的是恐怖，我一点也不认为它是一部恐怖电影。我认为——我的意思是，它确实是，我想那就像是一部惊悚片，对，它是一部惊悚片。
but you I mean you're dealing with a lot of like big issues you're asking a lot of questions and you're making some you're bringing up a lot of things that I think make some people uncomfortable and I think you're doing it in a way you're serving it in a way that is like maybe seems familiar
但你——我的意思是，你在处理很多重大议题，你在提出很多问题，你在引入很多东西，我认为这会让一些人感到不舒服。而且我觉得你这样做的方式，你呈现它的方式，
to them but then you're like but guess what motherfucker you better think about this and think about what the experience is other people who aren't you maybe having and you kind of do it and maybe us is about like our own you sort of mentioned it like it's very sort of
对他们来说可能看起来很熟悉，但随后你会说：“但猜猜看，你个混蛋，你最好考虑一下这个，考虑一下那些与你不同的人可能正在经历的体验。”而且你这样做——也许《我们》是关于我们自己的，你稍微提到了这一点，这是一种非常
an existential question about you know as human beings and blah blah blah I like the idea that you're you're kind of like I guess they're in horror but you're dealing with a lot of pretty fucking big universal issues it doesn't seem like you're you set out
关于人类本身的生存主义问题，云云。我喜欢这种想法，你有点像是——我想它们属于恐怖片，但你在处理很多非常他妈重大的普世议题。这看起来不像你是刻意去
to make a horror movie or a genre movie you're making seems like you're leading with theme and then kind of backing into well maybe this medicine will go down well if we wrap it up with something that's a little bit kind of scary here or sci-fi here
拍一部恐怖片或流派电影。你似乎是以主题为主导，然后退而求其次：好吧，如果我们把它包裹在有点可怕的东西或科幻的东西里，也许这个药丸会更容易吞下去。
I withdraw my question no but I mean in the same way that you lampooned it when you when you did key and peel man you did a lot of you took on so many sketches that you did where you took on the idea of race and challenged it and did it from a different perspective in ways
我收回我的问题。不，但就像你当年在《黑人兄弟》（Key & Peele）中恶搞时一样，你创作了那么多小品，探讨了种族的概念并对其发起挑战，从不同的视角去剖析，
that were really funny but also like really fucking right on the fucking money man and you've kind of you're kind of doing that same thing but now in it and you're doing it in film and you're using I mean I sound like now I sound like Babin but you're using light and you're using no when you're
既非常搞笑，又他妈的直击要害。你现在正在做类似的事情，但现在是在电影中，而且你正在使用——我的意思是，我现在听起来像贝特曼了，但你在用光影，你在用——不，当你在
you're doing it in a cinematic way like you're I like I think that you defy genre so anybody who says that Jordan Peele is this I say fuck that he's everything oh well yeah well thank you and at the same time you know just to stress you know I think a lot of people
以一种电影化的方式在做这件事时，就像你在——我认为你无视流派，所以任何说乔丹·皮尔是这样的人，我都想说去他的，他是万能的。哦，好吧，谢谢。与此同时，你知道，只是想强调一下，你知道，很多人
you know if I make any sort of distinctions from like the horror genre at all I I want you know a lot of people think a horror is a bad word sure I think it's actually the greatest genre and and I think it is
你知道，如果我对恐怖片流派做任何区分的话，我希望——你知道，很多人认为“恐怖”是一个贬义词。当然。我认为它实际上是最伟大的流派，而且我认为它是
one that I'm honored to to take part in the true I have to say the true spirit of great horror is really to fuck somebody up on some on some terror level that I still have not
一个我很荣幸能参与其中的流派。老实说，伟大恐怖片的真正精神，确实是在某种恐怖层面上把人整崩溃。我还没能
sort of approached the darkness that is needed so I just have so much respect for horror and I'm so I'm honored to be a part of it yeah and and I didn't mean to suggest that it wasn't that it wasn't worthy but at all as genres
接近这种所需的黑暗，所以我对恐怖片只有无限的敬意，我很荣幸能成为其中的一部分。是的，我并不是说它不值得，完全不是。作为各种流派，
go it's fucking great I agree with you I'm just saying that yeah I think that what you do kind of transcends transcends the idea of genre yeah and it seems like you're using it or attracted to it because of it it's it's power and it's accelerant for whatever sort of human condition
它他妈的太棒了。我同意你的看法，我只是说，是的，我觉得你所做的一切有点超越了流派的概念。是的，而且你似乎是因为它的力量和催化剂作用而使用它、被它吸引，来讲述你正在讨论的任何关于人类境况的故事。
story you're talking about like you know when you mention Kubrick like you think about you know the only thing that he ever did that was close to horror was the shining and there wasn't a lot of that wasn't you know there wasn't some slasher film you know that you know a bunch of jump scares it was just
就像——你知道，当你提到库布里克时，你会想到，你知道他拍过的唯一一部接近恐怖片的电影是《闪灵》，里面并没有太多——那不是什么砍杀电影，你知道的，没有什么一惊一乍的惊吓，它只是
deeply unsettling but it was earned through its filmmaking through its acting through its writing through its cinematic elements I mean like that's what you do you're not like anybody can like make a big sound and do a big you know fucking snap zoom or
深深地令人不安，但这是通过他的电影制作、他的表演、他的写作、他的电影元素赢得的。我的意思是，这就是你的所作所为。你不是那种——任何人都可以制造一个巨大的声音，做一个巨大的、他妈的猛烈推拉镜头或者
whip pan and like scare somebody you know like you're not doing that you're creating these environments that are unsettling and that's not easy to do and I just I think you're just like like the most exciting filmmaker we've got right now thank you man look
摇摄来吓唬人，你知道的，你不是在那样做。你在创造这些令人不安的环境，这可不容易做到。我只是觉得你简直就像……就像我们现在拥有最令人兴奋的电影人。谢谢你，老兄。听着，
I you guys are fucking awesome I mean I think you know just the last shit stories as in as in what you've been in a set in the middle of nowhere and you really got it out of the bathroom but there's nothing around there we go Sean's going to watch it on a set
你们俩太他妈棒了。我的意思是，我想你们知道，最后那些破事，比如当你在荒郊野岭的片场拍戏，你真的从洗手间里出来……周围什么也没有，我们要去了，肖恩要在片场看这个。
no no no I'm kidding you're just kidding but but no I mean let's just talk about the set portos for a second sure yeah yeah yeah you know yeah because you keep it real right you say no no I don't want the I don't want the double pop out thing just get me a honey wagon
不不不，我开玩笑的，你只是开玩笑，但，但是不，我的意思是，我们来聊聊片场的化妆车吧，当然，对，对，你知道，对，因为你很真实，对吧，你说不不，我不要那种，我不要那种双向弹出的东西，就给我来辆厕所车
yeah but you can't make it back to the honey yeah I mean you're talking about one of those fucking fourpies yeah he means the fourpies one of those four slots Jason doesn't have that he doesn't even know what he's talking about because he's he's goes to the bathroom once in the morning before
对，但是你回不去厕所，对，我的意思是，你在说那种该死的四格车，对，他指的是四格车，那种四个坑位的，杰森才没有那个，他甚至不知道自己在说什么，因为他一天去一次卫生间，在
shower and then he's never running the risk of going to the bathroom on set ever ever there's not a lot of animals on the planet that need to empty more than once a day will yeah you guys have a difference
洗澡之前，然后他从来不会冒在片场上厕所的风险，永远都不会，地球上没有多少动物需要一天排泄一次以上，好吧，你们两个有区别
in regularity yes we have a difference in regularity well listen I'm sorry to end on such a low point it wasn't that bad talking to us even just agreeing to do the show period yeah dude Jordan we're such
在规律性上，是的，我们在规律性上有区别，好吧，听着，很抱歉以这样一个低谷结束，和我们聊天其实没那么糟，哪怕只是同意做这个节目，是的，老兄，乔丹，我们真是
fans man I've been a fan of yours from everything you do I love what you do you're such a cool guy you haven't changed an iota so that's a great testament you're a good dude keep charging please thank you man you guys yeah on and on I love you love you this is
你的粉丝，老兄，我是你所有作品的粉丝，我喜欢你所做的一切，你真是个酷家伙，你一点也没变，所以这真是个很好的证明，你是个好家伙，请继续加油，谢谢你，老兄，你们，对，没完没了，我爱你们，爱你们，这真是
great I really hope I can come see you guys again yeah please more I'll come up with that scat story yeah good good scat story best of luck with with nope I'm gonna be first in line and hurry up and make more please
太棒了，我真的希望我能再来见你们，对，拜托，多来点，我会想出那个屎尿屁的故事，好的，好的，屎尿屁故事，祝你一切顺利，不，我要排在第一位，快点多拍点，求你了
and just to you know just to take the James Cameron approach for a second I you know I'm finishing this movie right now it will make your eyes melt out of the back of your eye sockets fall down in through your nasal
为了，你知道的，为了稍微采取詹姆斯·卡梅隆的方法，你知道，我正在完成这部电影，它会让你的眼球从眼眶后面融化掉，掉进你的鼻子里
and down your esophageal this is you selling the film you scat it out and and then you fucking eat you eat your eyes shit this is that we've got our quote and then you can see your own fucking heart pulse racing
顺着食道下去，这是你在推销这部电影，你把它拉出来，然后你他妈的吃掉，你吃掉你的眼球，操，这就是我们的金句，然后你可以看到你自己的该死的心跳加速
save it for the junket Jordan wasting all the good stuff you got the exclusive hot take um no no I just want to stress it's it's it's it's gonna be a fucking spectacle yeah I cannot wait it looks so can't wait for you guys to see it all right man
留着去新闻发布会说吧，乔丹，你把好料都浪费了，你拿到了独家猛料，嗯，不，不，我只是想强调，这，这，这，这绝对是一场该死的视觉盛宴，是的，我等不及了，看起来太，等不及让你们看到了，好了，伙计
best of luck thank you for coming on and we'll talk to you on the next one thank you guys honestly thank you Jordan I am I really I could get I could give you guys each I know will I know you I could give you guys each fucking solid power on neat notes
祝一切顺利，谢谢你能来，我们下次节目再聊，谢谢你们，说实话，谢谢你，乔丹，我真的，我可以，我可以给你们每一个人，我知道威尔，我知道你，我可以给你们每一个人他妈的好好写一些笔记
and how much I love your how much I love your work and so I didn't want to right back at you you guys are just fantastic I hope to hang yeah man that would be great luck dude take care Jordan bye buddy cool wow that Jordan
关于我多喜欢你的，我多喜欢你的作品，所以我不想，回敬你们，你们太棒了，希望能一起玩，老兄，那就太好了，祝你好运，老兄，保重，乔丹，再见，伙计，酷，哇，那个乔丹
peel that Jordan peel he has turned the movie industry on his goddamn head by he barged his way into films didn't he yeah it just kicked the door open and it stayed open and now
皮尔，那个乔丹·皮尔，他把整个电影行业搅得天翻地覆，他硬闯进了电影界，不是吗？是的，他直接把门给踢开了，而且门就一直开着，现在
he's bringing us I mean the horror genre is like one of the few genres that's working in in theaters still thank god yeah yeah but he's also but he's also doing it in such a cinematic way and he's like social themes that are in it so
他给我们带来了，我的意思是，恐怖片是少数现在还能在影院卖座的类型之一，谢天谢地，对，对，但他也，但他也是以一种极具电影感的方式在做，而且里面还加入了社会主题，所以
he's so fucking smart you can't write a show like he and peel and do that so consistently and so fit and have it be so good and so funny for all those years and not be a fucking brilliant guy and just show him again I hope he wasn't like offended when I said you know that we knew him from all this stuff
他他妈的太聪明了，你不可能写出一个像他和皮尔那样的节目，能一直保持那么稳定，而且那么棒，那么搞笑，历经那么多年，却不是一个绝顶聪明的人，再次向他致敬，我希望他不会因为我说我们是从那些老作品里认识他的而感到被冒犯
and then get out came out and I was like wow Jordan like didn't you know he's like no way I mean I was offended he wasn't I was yeah no I could see it in Will's face but not Jordan he's gotta he's gotta know that he's gotta I mean I'm sure I would hope that
然后《逃出绝命镇》上映了，我就想，哇，乔丹，难道你不知道吗，他就像是，没有啦，我的意思是，我被冒犯了，他没有，我，是的，不，我从威尔的脸上看出来了，但乔丹没有，他一定，他一定知道，我的意思是，我确信，我希望
that was part of his excitement too that like you know whenever you excel at something you're not known for it's gotta be a thrill and so also like yeah you can't be mad if you're like some person who came not him I don't mean to him specifically but you could see how people
这也是他兴奋的一部分，就是你知道的，无论你在哪个你不擅长的领域取得卓越成就，那一定是一种刺激，所以就像，是的，如果你是一个经历过那些的人，你不能生气，不是指他，我不是针对他个人，但你可以理解为什么人们
were like well yeah I've always thought I was great yeah well we didn't know yeah great yeah exactly and now we're now we're finding out that yeah you're great yeah exactly but I don't mean that for him I do think that what he did before I I always thought you know writing really consistently
会觉得，哦，是的，我一直觉得自己很棒，是的，好吧，我们以前不知道，是的，很棒，是的，没错，现在我们，现在我们发现，是的，你真的很棒，是的，没错，但我不是针对他，我确实认为他以前做过的那些，我一直觉得，你知道，写作真的非常稳定
good funny sketch like that doing it in that way is so hard yeah fucking you guys know it's almost impossible sketch is so uneven and and and and rarely people always go like oh I remember SNL back in the day was used to be way better than it is now is
拍出那样精彩好笑的小品短剧简直太难了，真的，他妈的你们也知道，几乎是不可能的。小品总是那么参差不齐，而且人们总会说：“哦，我记得当年的周六夜现场比现在好多了，以前是”
funnier all the time like no there was always if you had one good sketch an episode success yeah for sure and Key and Peele now they didn't do it live but they they would have just brilliant it's just brilliant anyway um when I have a question about the Dodger game yeah so
一直都更有趣。”才怪，以前只要一集里能有一个精彩的小品就算成功了。对，绝对是这样。而《黑人兄弟》现在——虽然他们不是现场直播，但他们的作品真是太棒了，简直绝妙。不管怎样，嗯，我有个关于道奇队比赛的问题，对，所以
um how long wait a second wait a second we we you want to talk about tonight's plans in front of our audience right now go ahead Sean they'll be sure they'd love to hear it where what root are you taking and where are you working what lot are you in do they have egg salad there do you think or should I eat before
嗯，等等，等一下，等一下，我们——你想当着我们观众的面聊今晚的安排吗？说吧，肖恩，他们肯定很想听听。你们走哪条路线？在哪个停车场？那里有鸡蛋沙拉吗？你觉得有吗？还是我应该在
I leave by the way all questions I have yeah let's hear it how long is the game oh my god he wants to leave already no no you even left your house yes you're getting ready to go tonight I didn't say how long is each half um it's a roughly
出门前先吃点？顺便说一句，这都是我的问题。对，说来听听，比赛要打多久？哦天哪，他已经想走了不不，你连家门都还没出呢。对，你正准备今晚去呢。我没说每个半局有多长，嗯，大概
three hours but you know you only need to dip in and dip out for about an hour that's probably all we're gonna do because I'm bringing you know Maple um and and probably with shorter attention span is Amanda in fact she may actually even flake I can't believe that you got Amanda to go no man will go well because you know it's a luxury
三个小时，但你知道的，你只需要去看个一小时左右就行了。那可能就是我们要做的全部了，因为我要带上，你知道的，枫树——而且阿曼达的注意力可能也比较短暂，事实上她甚至可能会放鸽子。我真不敢相信你能把阿曼达约去。不，阿曼达会去的，因为你知道的，这是个豪华
suite you know so she she can be up there and uh you know watching the TV and and having snacks and sitting on a couch it's a luxury suites I'm just imagining that Paul McCartney explaining to somebody who he loves who he calls sweet and he's like why all of a sudden are we
包厢，所以她可以待在那里，你知道的，看看电视，吃吃零食，坐在沙发上。这是个豪华包厢。我只是在想象保罗·麦卡特尼向他深爱的人解释，他叫她“甜心”，然后他问，为什么突然我们
it's a luxury sorry because we're back it's a luxury suite did you find a gummy store there in the Hamptons well no it does it does it does seem like a very high thing to say are you gonna bring your own food Jace are you going to no man buy it
是个豪华包厢，抱歉，因为我们回来了，这是个豪华包厢。你在汉普顿找到软糖店了吗？噢不，这听起来确实是一件很高大上的事情。你要自己带吃的去吗，杰斯？还是你打算——不，老兄，买现成的
buy it buy it I love Sean's he always he always goes high with it and he repeats it we're having a conversation over here and you're trying to do a buy on your own and like if you have a hard out
买现成的，买现成的。我太喜欢肖恩了，他总是把事情说得很高大上，而且他会重复一遍。我们正聊着呢，你却想自己接话，就好像如果你有一个硬性规定
what if I just slam my left I guess buy I guess it counts well a better better answered here you know you will be out by 10 o'clock tonight Bye Smart
要不我直接关掉左边的……我猜买吧，我猜这算数。好吧，这里回答得更好，你知道的，你今晚十点前就能出来。拜，“聪明”，
Loss Smart Loss SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Rob Armjurf Bennett Barbicow and Michael Grant Terry
“损失”，聪明损失。《SmartLess》由罗布·阿尔姆朱夫、本尼特·巴比考和迈克尔·格兰特·特里100%有机手工打造。
SmartLess I'm very excited that you're here oh my gosh my friend not more than I am not more than I am I cannot wait impossible yeah okay so you've met Bennett and Rob I am
《SmartLess》，我很高兴你能来。噢天哪，我的朋友，我比你更激动！我比你更激动！我等不及了，太不可能了。好吧，所以你已经见过本尼特和罗布了，我
sorry I met these guys on Jason's behalf we apologize for us the weird part is that Rob nor Bennett play any musical instrument at all that's the shocking part these are just CG backgrounds I don't believe it
很抱歉，我是代表杰森跟这几位见面的，我们为此道歉。奇怪的是，罗布和本尼特其实都不会任何乐器，这才是最令人震惊的部分。这些都只是CG背景，我才不信呢。
this is a jam band that produced a new part Rob that's a real strong t-shirt you're bringing today show them the bottom show them the other stuff the in the studio behind the pro tools rig is the best is he playing a
这是一支制作了新专辑的即兴乐队。罗布，你今天穿的这件T恤真够酷的，给他们看看背面，看看其他部分。在Pro Tools录音设备后面的那个最棒，他在弹
keytar on the back I love it it is like it really is a very bootleg Han Zimmer shirt we went to Disneyland for Rob Andrea's birthday recently they were both wearing this shirt
背后的琴键吉他吗？我太喜欢了。这真的很像一件盗版的汉斯·季默T恤。我们最近去迪士尼乐园庆祝罗布·安德烈亚斯的生日，他们两个都穿着这件
at Disneyland matching can I tell you something I also have a picture I have a shirt that has Han Zimmer's face and the name Han Zimmer on it no way a completely different shirt I'm not joking
T恤去迪士尼乐园，穿的还是情侣装。我跟你说个事，我还有一张照片，我有一件T恤上面印着汉斯·季默的脸和“汉斯·季默”的名字。绝不可能！完全不同的T恤，我没开玩笑。
the idea that there's actually two shirts in existence on the planet that have Han Zimmer's name and face on it and the two dudes that have them this is everything there's very little I can do to actually make it clear that I do have that Kismet
世界上居然存在两件印有汉斯·季默名字和脸的T恤，而且正好被这两个家伙拥有，这真是太奇妙了。我几乎没什么办法能清楚地证明我确实有那件衣服，这就是天意。
should we let Will Arnett in the room I'm going dark awesome here we go There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们该让威尔·阿奈特进房间了吗？我要变黑了。太棒了，我们开始吧。这个节目还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。